if you're stuck if you're struggling if  you if you're being dismantled if you  feel like your life is getting pulled  out from underneath you  I say  congratulations like what a [ __ ]  opportunity that is you are being given  an opportunity to look at yourself  and reconstruct your life from the  ground up not everybody gets that  opportunity and it holds the potential  energy to create something entirely new  if you're willing to respect it and give  it the attention it deserves when you're  in that place it can feel like you're  going to be there forever but if you  devote yourself to that path of  self-understanding and you respect the  struggle I'm convinced that no problem  is unsolvable because I've seen  thousands of lives transformed  over the years